実はこのDollarEmitはイベントを発生させる時に同時にデータを親コンポーネントに渡すこともできるんですね
今回はそれについて紹介したいと思います
どうするかっていうと単純にこのDollarEmitの第2引数に渡したいデータを入れるんですね
例えばリセットする時に値を0じゃなくて100にしたいということで100を入れるとします
これを親コンポーネント側でどうやって受け取ることができるのかというと
実はイベントオブジェクトと同じようにインラインハンドラーであればDollarEventでその値を受け取ることができます
なので今カウントに直接DollarEventを代入しているので100が代入されるということで
今ですねカウントを足してリセットをするとこんなに100になります
もう一度リセットを押すと100に戻るという風になります
逆にメソッドハンドラーの場合
ちょっと例えばですけれども
ファンクションオンリセットという関数を作るとしますね
その上でこのオンリセットをですね指定したいと思います
この時もイベントオブジェクトと同じような感じで
ここのメソッドハンドラーの引数にこの100という数字が入りますので
例えばですけれども
カウント.valueイコールvalueとすることで
これでもですねリセットボタンを押すと100になりますし
カウントアップしても無地度100に戻るという風になります
なのでこのEmitを使ったココンポーネントから
親コンポーネントへの通信は
データを渡すこともできるんですね
これも非常に便利ですのでぜひ知っておいてください
このデータに関しましても
Propsとは違って
勝手に親コンポーネント側のデータが更新されるというわけではなくて
あくまでもイベントが発生した時にデータを渡すだけで
それをどう使うかというのは
親コンポーネント側で明示的に書く必要があります
なのでそこまでデータの流れが分からなくなるということはありませんので
安心してご使用ください
普通のイベントオブジェクトと同じような感じで使えるわけですね
ということで親から子にデータを渡す時はProps
逆に子から親にデータを渡す時はEmit
これがですね
Vue.jsのコンポーネント間の通信における
基本的な考え方であり
非常に重要な考え方ですので
ぜひですね
知っておいてください
では次は
実はDefinePropsと同じような感じで
DefineEmitというものもあったりしますので
それについて次のレクチャーで説明したいと思います
DefineProps